If I were a smart musician,
I would have done what the other smart
musicians did,
which is only licensed your music in
places where they don't speak English.
That's,
I mean all the credible musicians,
I don't want to name names,
but they don't license their music in
the UK or the states.
They license it.
And Portugal are they licensed it and
South Korea or Japan and that way the
tastemakers,
you know,
the music journalists never hear about
it.
But it's,
it's a strange phenomenon because,
I mean,
I have been criticized for licensing my
music to commercials,
but it's odd for a few reasons.
One,
that most of the journalists who've
criticized me write for publications
that are wholly funded by ad revenue.
You know,
so there'll be an article criticizing me
for liking my music to commercials and
on the next page,
and an ad for Ford or budweiser or what
have you.
And the same journalists who are people
who criticize me for licensing my music.
Actually,
you know,
by the products that are being
advertised.
And I don't know,
I,
maybe it's the old punk rocker in me.
I always thought it was cooler to take
money from a big corporation and to give
money to a big corporation.
So I have regrets that I did too much
licensing.
Um,
and I should have as I had been smart
and done what everyone else does is only
licensed it to South Korea and Japan.
When play came out,
uh,
at first it didn't have any success.
You know,
the reviews weren't very good.
It didn't sell very well,
and then it sort of picked up momentum
and became a successful record.
So at first the only,
the only way I had to get people to make
people aware of the music was by
licensing it to movies,
TV shows,
advertisement.
So we did a lot of it.
Uh,
in hindsight,
I think I did too much of it.
There's another ironic aspect of it,
which is that at the time people in the
music business be,
they're musicians or record executives,
heap scorn on me for doing this.
And that was all the same record
executives are all working at licensing
companies or they're working at record
labels where they're desperate to
license anything.
And there's a lot of the musicians who
also criticized me are now bending over
backwards and frustrating prostrating
themselves to try and get their music
licensed.
So I think that unfortunately,
I don't mean this in a positive way.
I was sort of the avant garde of
licensing.
You know,
I was like the shock troop of licensing.
So as a result I got killed first,
you know,
so now everyone does it and no one's
really criticized for it.
Um,
but yes,
in hindsight,
I definitely did way too much of it.
But the only reason I got involved in
the music business,
it was because I love music and I want
to make music.
And selfishly I'd like people to hear
the music that I make.
Um,
I'm not too concerned with the
commercial ramifications of producing
and producing music and putting it out
into the world.
If people want to buy my music,
fine.
If they don't want to,
that's fine with me too.
Uh,
again,
my,
my only interest in the commercial side
of the music business is to try and get
people to hear the music that I've made.
You know,
so I don't,
I don't look at the music business and
think how can I make a lot of money from
it?
I look at it and I think,
how can I strategically try and get
people to hear the music that I've made?
And so when I look at that,
the fact that the record companies are
falling apart and revenue streams are
dying,
drying up and royalties or you know,
a 10th what they used to be for a lot of
people,
um,
it doesn't concern me.
Um,
some from sort of like a fiduciary
perspective,
it only concerns me from a musician's
perspective where I just hope that in
the future I'm able to make music that
people will be willing to listen.